well good evening for London welcome to
Piers Morgan on censored reviews for
Harry and Megan's big budget Netflix
series have so far been less than kind
unimaginative and frustrating said
Hollywood's Bible variety magazine so
sickening I almost brought up my
breakfast said the woke Bible the
guardian or the intimacy of Instagrams
near the normally timid New York Times a
nauseating self-serving snooze Fest said
another pundit well that was me actually
now against this Deluge of derision
Netflix today released a new trailer for
the second half of this compelling
series which comes out on Thursday
viewer discretion is advised this clip
contains weapons-grade hypocrisy
I wonder what would have happened to us
had we not gone out when we did our
security was being pulled everyone in
the world knew where we were I said we
need to get out of here
on the freedom flight
to see this institutional gaslighting I
wasn't being thrown to the Wolves I was
being fed to the Wolves they were
actively recruiting people to
disseminate disinformation they're happy
to lie to protect my brother they were
never willing to tell the truth to
protect us Prince Harry and Megan Markle
the Rogue Royals
they just wanted to be free
they wanted to be free to love and be
happy
I applauded that
in order for us to be able to move to
the next chapter you've got to finish
the first chapter it gave us a chance to
create that home that we had always
wanted
[Music]
I've always felt as though this was a
fight Worth Fighting For
institutional gaslighting says Harry do
you think even knows what that means
they were happy to lie to protect my
brother who the Royals
me the media who is it the irony is
earth-shattering isn't it Harry and
Megan the Duke and Duchess of
gaslighting themselves the entire show
is a cynical attempt to manipulate
viewers into questioning their own
Recollections of reality
and if we learned anything at all from
the first three hours of this hundred
million dollar wine-a-thon it's surely
that this dismal Duo wouldn't know the
truth if it's smack them around their
smug chops let's look at their Truth
versus the actual truth
Mega moans at Royal advisors forced her
to uninvite her dear niece Ashley from
the wedding the only member of her
family that she seemed to be still
talking to
how do we explain that this half-sister
isn't invited to the wedding but that
the half-sister's daughter is
so
Ashley the guidance at the time was to
not have her come to our wedding
yeah that was a lie
impeccably placed Royal sources told the
Sunday Times no such guidance was ever
given
and that was supposed to be the show's
big example of how Megan really cares
very deeply about her family so deeply
that only one member of that family was
at the wedding her mother not even her
favorite little niece Ashley
Megan also sees she got no advice on
Royal protocol forcing her to learn how
to be a princess all on her own
joining this family I knew that there
was a protocol for how things were done
there is no class and some person who
goes sit like this cross your legs like
this use this Fork don't do this curtsy
then wear this kind of hat it doesn't
happen
another lie and by the way Megan if you
don't like me calling you a liar just
sue me and we'll go through all this in
court there's suddenly times discovered
she was actually handed a 30-point
dossier studiously research brimming
with information and contacts Megan
later simpas that she never wore bright
colors to show respect because she's all
about respect
so I was like well what's a color that
they'll probably never wear
camel beige white so I wore a lot of
muted tones but it also was
so I could just blend in
like I'm not trying to stand out here
no the last thing Mega mark would ever
want to do is stand out but it's all one
other life photos taken by the evil
bigoted British press show her wearing
pretty much every color in the rainbow
the show opens with a claim that they're
all family declined to comment on the
series that's another lie the palace
says it received one email from an
unknown company an attempts to verify it
but flatly ignored even the story of
their romance and engagement turns out
to be in a series of Whoppers they told
the BBC in 2017 they were set up by a
mutual friend on a blind date they told
Netflix they met on Instagram and what
about Harry's Modest Proposal in their
humble cottage kitchen
uh it happened a few weeks ago earlier
this month here at our Cottage
um it's a standard typical night for us
cozy night it was what are we doing just
roasting chicken
Chinese chicken and it was just
an amazing surprise it was so sweet an
amazing surprise it was so sweet well
according to Netflix which is their show
it was actually a candle Extravaganza in
their Walled Garden
and Megan was so amazingly surprised she
managed to figure out what was happening
and tell her friend about it before
Harry even popped the question
a small little detail but rather like
their claim or Megan's claim that they'd
been secretly married by the Archbishop
of Canterbury in their Garden before
three days before the big televised
wedding which also turned out not just
to be untrue but had it been true would
have led to the Archbishop of a country
with being incarcerated in prison
as with all things Megan and Harry it
would seem the truth just doesn't really
exist in their world it's their truth
their version of it
Megan also lambasted the entire BBC
engagement interviews rehearsed and an
orchestrated reality show because that's
the last thing she'd be engaging in
isn't it an orchestrated reality show
like the Netflix series
Michelle Hussein from the BBC who
carried out the interview said actually
no it was just an interview even the
BBC's long-serving Royal correspondent
Nicholas witchell normally bent double
to avoid upsetting absolutely anybody in
Royal circles can't take it anymore
consider one of the things that Megan
said no matter what I did they were
still going to find a way to destroy me
well the first point who is the they
that she's referring to I think it is
the palace but most particularly it is
to the Press but the idea that anyone
was out to destroy her frankly I think
is absurd and simply does not stand up
to a proper and reasonable scrutiny well
that's Nicholas witchell's way of saying
you're lying and he's right
they lie all the time nothing they ever
say seems to stand up to reasonable
scrutiny and I say that as somebody who
lost his last job presenting Good
Morning Britain because I wouldn't
apologize for saying I didn't believe
Meghan Markle think about that
well just like they've failed to ever
provide a shred of evidence for their
claims of racism in the palace or
Megan's claims over mental health
problems she said that they were not
just ignored by the palace but she was
told she wasn't allowed to get any help
for Suicidal Thoughts by somebody at the
palace who was that person
they shouldn't be working at the palace
we've never had a name like we've never
had any names about the racism
today's new trailer makes clear that the
gloves are off in the next three
episodes of the show and remember this
is just a warm-up and there's Harry's
book coming in early January
hundreds of pages of more allegations
about his family
there will be mudslinging incendiary
claims Bombshells and I fear a lot more
lies and on behalf of the British people
the monarchy they're trashing I intend
to call out every single lie that they
utter in their attempt to not just
destroy the royal family but to
potentially bring down the British
Monarchy